hi guys
scifi recapped here
before we start
warning
spoilers ahead
today
i'm gonna explain a 2021 american
science fiction and adventure movie
called clifford the big red dog the
movie begins in an abandoned warehouse
where a mother dog is taking care of her
puppies suddenly two officers come in
and take them separating the mother from
her puppies however the men do not know
that there is one bright red puppy
hiding under the blanket he tries to
chase after them but he is just too late
and is left alone long story short he
manages to get out of the warehouse
elsewhere in new york emily elizabeth
howard has just received a scholarship
and moves to a new school until now she
still doesn't have any friends she lives
in an apartment whose owner is very
demanding and talkative emily's mother
maggie who works as a paralegal is a
very busy person
emily shares that she is still getting
teased by one of her classmates florence
because she is small and a scholarship
grantee to cheer her daughter up maggie
says that unique people are the ones
that change the world
a few moments later she informs her
daughter that she has to leave her with
a sitter for a work emergency emily is
okay with whoever the sitter is as long
as she or he is not uncle casey on the
other side uncle casey maggie's younger
brother is homeless and lives in a van
an officer shows up telling him to move
away and pay some fine he ignores her
and rushes to an office for a job
interview upon arrival he approaches a
woman who tells him that he is an hour
late he then leaves the office with
disappointment and sadness breaking the
company's logo emily goes out around the
neighborhood to collect cans and bottles
for her school's fundraiser while doing
it she meets malik the magician miss
cullerman the cranky neighbor lawyer
couple mr and mrs jarvis and bodega
owner sanchez
emily returns to the apartment and is
very surprised and also disappointed
when she finds out that casey is going
to be the sitter
after telling casey everything that must
be done maggie leaves
back to the red dog he starts exploring
the city finding himself in the middle
of traffic he arrives at a park where
the red puppy meets mr bridwell who
decides to bring the puppy with him the
next day casey takes emily out into the
city where she gets excited as she spots
a tent for rescued animals they enter a
tent discover several animals like a
rabbit sloth and a snake they're then
welcomed by the owner who turns out to
be mr bridwell he brings them to the
little red puppy emily is very excited
and seems that the puppy also likes her
emily asked mr bridwell how the big dog
will grow and he says that it will
depend on how much she loves him
although she instantly falls in love
with the red puppy and begs casey's
permission to bring him home casey
rejects the request and both of them
leave the tent emily then arrives at
school where she is teased again by
florence for collecting cans for the
charity
a few moments later
owen the geeky student who has a slight
crush on emily suddenly appears in
sports emily saying that she is awesome
in class emily is embarrassed when her
plastic bag full of cans breaks open and
spills the cans in front of everyone she
then returns home with sadness and
embarrassment upon arrival at her
apartment she is very surprised when she
finds the red puppy magically having
stowed away in her backpack
after several attempts emily decides to
name him clifford after the puppy shows
the sign that he loves the name clifford
is hungry and sneaks outside emily's
bedroom he steals casey's meat and is
very shocked when he sees the little
puppy after a long negotiation casey
allows clifford to stay for one night
and she has to return him back to mr
bridwell since pets are not allowed in
the building
before sleeping she wishes that they
could be big and strong so nobody will
ever hurt them while one of her tears
rolls into clifford's nose
the next morning
emily awakens and is very shocked to see
that clifford has become gigantic
however he's still the same clifford
that obeys emily
emily tries to explain the situation to
casey while the giant clifford shows up
and freaks casey out they try to find a
way to deal with him but mr packard the
building superintendent suddenly comes
by to fix the dishwasher
long story short after a large effort to
hide a dog mr packard finishes his job
and leaves the apartment
casey suggests emily to take clifford to
the vet and then try to find mr bridwell
to return a giant dog
they try to hide the dog in casey's van
but owen suddenly shows up asking why
she didn't show up at school and
unintentionally attracts people around
them who start taking pictures of
clifford clifford spots a giant plastic
bubble thinking that he can fetch it he
immediately runs towards it and chases
the bubble until he pops it at a biotech
company like fegaro ceo zach tirin and
his team are developing a formula to
make food grow bigger
however the experiments don't show any
progress
even though it's progressing the results
are not what they expected which makes
tyrion furious clifford becomes viral
and his assistant colette shows tier and
pictures of 10 foot clifford in the
social media he thinks clifford can be
the solution to save his company he
plans to inject an id chip inside
clifford's body thus he can claim him as
a company's property
his team discovers that emily is seen
frequently with the dog so he orders
them to trace her they arrive at emily's
apartment and tyron reveals to the
superintendent that she has been keeping
an animal in the building for the whole
time
emily owen and casey eventually managed
to bring clifford to the vet who is
surprised to see a 10-foot dog in front
of him
while examining clifford the vet asked
casey to help him take clifford's
temperature in the animal temperature
taking place
but he refuses to do so in the end the
vet determines that clifford is a very
healthy dog
emily and owen talk to lucille an
employee at the clinic who knows
bridwell she shares that all animals
that were given by him have helped the
owners out in their hard times however
she can't help them locate mr bidwell
emily remembers that bridwell just set
up his tent at school yesterday thus she
suggests they go to the school to find
the paperwork that contains information
about him casey manages to distract the
administrator while owen steals the
information from the computer in the
cafeteria florence confronts emily and
attempts to bully her again until
clifford shows up and becomes the main
attention to the students this time
emily fights back by saying that she is
envious because the dog is taking away
the attention from her clifford then
humiliates florence by licking her and
covering her in drool
she runs away as all the other students
laugh at her they then return to the
apartment only to find out they have
been evicted by packard because he found
that they had a dog in there outside mr
jarvis is installing a new satellite
antenna and suddenly slips he loses his
grip and falls but clifford manages to
rescue him
people there are very happy with the dog
a few moments later owen finds a letter
and manages to locate mr clifford who
will be at a hospital tomorrow tierra
and his team arrive and attempt to take
clifford back claiming that clifford is
the company's dog
tiaran even offers money to emily but
she refuses to take the money albert
staff of life figaro manages to inject
the id chip clifford runs away while
rawl and casey fight tiaran's men owen
and emily hide clifford in casey's van
emily then drives the van even though
she's not allowed to and manages to
transport him into owen's apartment
casey arrives and is surprised when he
finds out that owen is actually a rich
boy owens dog appears and awkwardly
wants to smell clifford's butt
clifford tries to play with him and ends
up licking him and almost swallowing him
on the other side tiaram goes to the
police and speaks to chief watkins
claiming that clifford escaped from life
vegro and he is a very dangerous animal
thus he must be captured immediately
a few moments later the police make a
public statement offering a reward for
clifford's capture owen's dad just
returns home when he finds a 10-foot red
dog wandering around in his building
he then offers emily help by
transporting clifford to china where he
would be very safe and treated well
however emily rejects the offer because
clifford is the best part of her life
and she is now willing to abandon him as
a last resort casey accepts emily's plan
to go to the hospital tomorrow to find
mr bridwell the next day they go to the
hospital where they find mr bridwell's
bow tie
however a patient tells them that the
man they are looking for has just passed
away which makes emily sad left with no
option emily reluctantly agrees to let
clifford go to china
she says her last words to the dog
apologizing for not being able to save
him the next day maggie sees news of
clifford with emily's image causing her
to rush home casey and emily learned
that the man who has passed away at the
hospital was not mr bridwell owen shows
up and tells them that mr bridwell's
tent is currently in the park where
emily's met clifford for the first time
however news reports that clifford was
captured and was sent to life figaro's
lab
knowing that they will hurt clifford the
trio and other people in the bodega who
offer their help immediately head over
to life egrow while tiaran is giving a
public statement the gang sneaks into
life fekro's building
however they triggered the fire alarm
causing all test animals to be set free
and creating chaos they arrive at their
room where clifford is being kept
managed to knock out the guard and set
clifford free emily and clifford
immediately rushed to the park while the
experiment animals take revenge upon the
scientists casey grabs a reporter's mic
and reveals the truth to the public
saying that tierra has been lying and
clifford belongs to emily maggie sees
the news and immediately heads over to
the park long story short after dodging
the police and tiaran's men they finally
arrive at the park where mr bridwell has
been waiting for them emily asked for
the old man's help but he states that it
was emily's love that made him so big
and there is no way to make him small
again a few moments later the police and
emily's friends arrive while park
visitors gather as they are amazed by
clifford mr bridwell suggests emily to
speak up she eventually delivers an
impassioned speech to the crowd about
how she and clifford are different she
states that being different is what
makes them special and it doesn't mean
they are harmful to anyone the crowd
agrees and supports her to keep clifford
with her however tiaran suddenly shows
up and attempts to reclaim clifford from
emily but when tiaran tells the police
to check the id chip on clifford the
scanner reveals that clifford belongs to
emily tiaran is left humiliated and the
crowd is allowed to get closer to the
dog at the end of the movie emily and
maggie are allowed to stay in mr
packer's apartment while casey finally
gets a job the city then also decides to
build a giant doghouse for clifford
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching